JARED COLE: Whether you're
a product manager, a CMO,
or a CEO, chances are
you're facing many
of the same problems every day.
How do you find new users?
How do you keep them?
And how do you get them to
invest a little bit more?
I'm assuming that the
people in this room
know a fair amount
about this question.
And I'm assuming a
fair number of you
also know that 50% of users find
new apps and games through word
of mouth from their friends
and from their family.
And research tells
us that 50% of users
are more likely to engage
with an app over a long period
of time if they
can actually use it
with their friends and family.
Yet more often than not,
we dedicate our resources,
our time, and our
money to the other 50%
of users looking at
indicators and incentives that
are targeting individual users
taking individual actions.
And why do we do this?
The answer is pretty simple.
It's easier to measure.
And it's easier to understand.
We know exactly how
long it takes somebody
to fulfill a specific
task within an app.
We know exactly how
many people click
through the ad in the game.
But these tend to be
lagging indicators.
Markers of decisions
that we've already made.
And so, clearly,
there's a gap here.
We should be thinking about
the forward looking indicators.
The decisions that help us
get to that other 50% of users
that are harder to measure.
The ones that are motivated by
word of mouth to find new apps.
The ones that have community and
relationship to drive long term
engagement.
And so my name is Jared,
and with me as Sam.
We're from Context Partners.
Those of you that
don't know us, we're
based in Portland, Oregon.
We focus heavily on
insights and engagement
and have decades of experience
strengthening relationships,
growing communities,
and building loyalty
for brands and causes.
For this project, we
partnered with three
incredible organizations.
Gameloft--
[MIC FEEDBACK]
Gameloft, Butterscotch
Shenanigans, and Freeletics.
Three organizations
that understand
the value of relationships
and the power of community.
We started by interviewing their
developers and their community
managers, trying to understand
what really is working for them
and what isn't from
their perspective.
And then we spoke to their users
to understand what's actually
working and what's not.
And to do this, we used a wide
variety of qualitative research
methodology, but
focused primarily
on surveys and interviews
to understand the role
that apps and games play
in their users lives.
And this gave us a window into
how people were talking about
apps, how they were
recommending apps--
in person and through
text conversations--
as well as realizing
how they are using apps
with each other in person
and across long distances.
And very quickly we realized
that not all word of mouth
is created equal.
Not every relationship
leads to engagement.
And through all of
these conversations,
we heard the same refrain.
People want more
human connection.
Especially with people who
love the things that they love.
And especially with people
who care about the things
that they care about.
When people have these
kinds of connections,
that's when you see word of
mouth driving to adoption.
Is this is better?
Thank you.
Today, we're going to
look at how and why users
have these kinds of
connected experiences.
We're going to look at how
developers create opportunities
for meaningful connection.
And we're going to
encourage you to change
the way that you
think about the way
that you approach your work.
Over the next 20
minutes or so, we're
going to introduce you
to three principles
that we've seen to be
most effective in driving
towards connected experiences.
Investigating
personal affinities
as clues to underlying values.
Challenging users to
reach beyond themselves
to connect with others.
And finally, creating
unexpected connections that
make experiences feel magical.
And as you hear
these stories, I want
you to continue
to think about how
to bring this back
to your own work,
into your day-to-day life.
Now I'm going to ask Sam to
share a few of the stories that
emerged over the course
of the research conducted
for this project.
SAM FOULGER: Thank you, Jared.
I'm so excited to speak with
you today about the things
that we learned from getting to
know these developers, users,
and players.
And, as you listen
to them, I want
you to be thinking about
the mindsets behind many
of the stories that
you're going to hear,
not just the specific tactics
that these developers used.
Because over and over
we heard that you
need to design for your
specific communities
in their specific moments.
So we have a lot to
get through today.
Let's get started.
On this first mindset, I want
you to think about something
that we all know.
We all know that
we should be giving
our users what they want.
If what they want is a
feeling of progression,
we're going to deliver that
feeling of progression.
If what they want are
high quality graphics,
we're going to deliver
high quality graphics.
And if what they
want is astronomy,
we're going to give
them the stars.
But the opportunity that
we saw was for developers
to look beyond just thinking
about what their users like
and using those affinities
as breadcrumb trails
that you can follow
to the deeper values
that your users will love
to build communities around.
We heard from a user
of the Star Walk 2 app.
This is an augmented reality
app for staring at the sky
and learning about
constellations.
And, clearly, this was a
user who loved the stars.
But what we heard
from him was that he
was having these connected
experiences with the app.
He was using it with his
father, with his uncle.
They were tracking
celestial objects
across long distances
with each other.
And what was driving that
connection wasn't just
an affinity for the stars,
it was the shared value
that they had.
The sense of wonder that you
get when you look up at the sky.
And we saw the
same thing when we
spoke to users of Gameloft's
Dragon Mania Legends.
This is Debbie and
her daughter Hannah.
And Debbie told us that
she plays this game
because her daughter
recommended it to her.
Debbie plays this game
because she loves dragons.
And so we kept talking
to Debbie and we
said, where does this love
of dragons come from, Debbie?
And she said, well,
my whole family
loves mythological creatures.
I raised my kids in the arts.
I would take them to Renaissance
fairs when they were kids.
I try to take them to the
limits of their imagination.
So when Hannah recommended
this to Debbie,
they weren't connecting over
that affinity for dragons.
They were connecting
over that deeper value
of imagination and a family.
And we saw this
over and over again
in the broader spectrum
of Android users
that we looked at.
The people who want to
connect over calendar apps
want to connect over
the value of respect
when it comes to
other people's time.
The people who choose body
weight apps over gym equipment
want to connect with people
over the value of discipline
and making no excuses when
it comes to their health.
And the couple who's tracking
their finances together
is connecting over the value
of commitment and saying,
I'm committed to our future.
But how did we know that these
users were expressing deeper
values and they
weren't just connecting
over these affinities?
Well, for this part
of our research,
we sent dozens of Android
users out into the real world
to capture the
conversations they were
having around apps and games.
They brought us into
their dinner parties,
into their lunch breaks at
work, into their text message
conversations.
And what we saw is something
I think a lot of you know.
People love to talk
about apps and games.
They love to share apps and
games with their friends.
But so many of
those conversations
don't lead to more
app adoption, don't
lead to ongoing engagement.
And we wanted to figure out why.
What we learned is that not all
word of mouth is created equal.
We heard from users
of finance apps
like Mint and Chase Mobile.
And these users would tell us,
I love recommending these apps
to my friends.
I show them these
beautiful pie charts.
I tell them about the
amazing typography.
I try to tell them how easy
it is to use these apps.
And yet, my friends
don't use them.
Even when I go so
far as to install
the app on their phone
for them, they still
don't start using the app.
But when we talk to users
who were successful,
who did get their friends
to start using apps,
we heard something
very different.
We heard from a
Mint user who said,
I struggle with my finances.
So I asked a friend
of mine who looked
like she had it all together.
And I said, how do you do it?
How do you stay on
top of your money?
My friend told me,
it's hard for me too.
I use Mint so I can see
how I'm spending my money
and try to do a little
bit better next month.
It's hard for me too.
These aren't two people who
are connecting over an affinity
for pie charts or typography.
These are people connecting
over their deeper
values of control
and struggle when
it comes to their finances.
So today is about mindsets.
And what we want you
to think about here
is how to look beyond just
your users affinities.
Take what they like
as the beginning
of the journey of learning
about the deeper values
that people love to
build communities around.
This is work that's a lot more
fun to do than you might think.
We do it a lot at
Context Partners.
And if we think of it as
ethnographic research,
or you think of it as
qualitative research studies,
it can sound really daunting.
But what we're
really talking about
is giving your users space to
tell you their stories, what
your app really means to them.
And this will make your
decision making easier
because you'll know
which parts of your app
really connect to those
deeper values that are driving
your word of mouth engagement.
Now today, what I
want you all to do
is think about a project
you're working on right now,
a decision you're
facing, something
you're going to have a
meeting about tomorrow.
And I want you to
plug that decision
into a series of questions.
Here's our first one.
And ask, will this feature
that I'm working on,
this new app that
I'm developing,
this marketing campaign
that I'm putting together
connect with what's truly
meaningful to our users?
Because answering
this question is
how you're going to appeal
to that 50% of users
who finds their apps and
games through word of mouth.
This is how you're
going to appeal
to that 50% of users who will
be more engaged with apps
that they can use with
their friends and family
because it's those
values that they're
going to be connecting over.
And if you're having trouble
answering this question,
it's a good time to take
a step back and learn
which of your users affinities
map to those deeper values.
So this is the
first step as we're
building these bridges
of connected experience.
First, we need to get
to know our users.
And we recommend digging into
their personal affinities
to find their underlying values.
Next, we need to get our
users outside of themselves.
And one of the most effective
ways we saw developers
doing this is by
using challenges
to motivate their users
to reach out to others.
To illustrate this,
I want you to think
about a moment in
your life when there's
something you desperately
wanted that was
just out of your reach.
Something that you just
couldn't quite get to alone.
What did you do?
Did you give up?
Or did you reach out for help?
I want you to think about
a moment in your life
when you truly accomplished
something great, something
that meant a lot to you
and it was really hard.
What did you want
to do right after?
I know for me, I want to
tell other people about it.
And not just anybody,
I want to tell
the people who understand, who
know what I've been through,
who know what it's like.
And that's what we heard from
so many of these Android users.
In the stories they would tell
us about their favorite apps
and games, we heard these
stories of challenge,
of struggle, of overcoming.
Those were the best stories.
The ones that made us
want to try new apps.
Apps like Freeletics.
In a lot of ways, Freeletics
is built around this concept
of challenge.
They're company that
makes several health apps.
And they're best known
for one that coaches users
through bodyweight exercises.
Over the past five
years, they've built--
not just a big user
base, 20 million users--
but an active user community.
People who work out together in
public at Freeletics training
spots around the world.
And what was so striking when we
spoke to these Freeletics users
was the pride in their voices.
The passion they felt
about Freeletics.
So much of that passion came
from how hard the workouts are.
That's all we heard
from users like Elliot.
I'll tell you right
now, Elliot is
a user you want if you
care about community.
Because Elliot is
the kind of person
who shows up at
training spots and he
welcomes new users warmly.
It's important to him that
people have a great first time
at these training spots.
He's the kind of user who
doesn't just buy the premium
subscription for himself, he
buys premium subscriptions
as gifts for his
friends and family.
And when I asked Elliot,
this incredible user,
what did you like about
Freeletics when you first
started using it?
This is what he told me.
He really didn't.
His exact words were, liked
isn't the word I would use.
He said it was too intense.
But at that moment in
his life, that intensity,
that challenge was exactly
what he was looking for.
Freeletics delivered it.
And now this is what he says.
The people I work out with are
the people I hang out with.
He welcomes new users warmly.
He buys premium subscriptions
for other people.
Why?
Because he wants other
people who know what
it's like, who've
experienced the challenge.
And we heard this from every
Freeletics user we spoke to.
They all want to be
around other people who
know what it means to train.
Multiple people said, I
want to be around people
who remember the pain.
How often do we think about
removing pain from our users?
And these users
are telling you, I
want to be around other
people who remember the pain.
Because it's that
pain that drives
them to reach out to others.
And I know some of you are
probably thinking, well, yeah,
this is a fitness app.
People want to be
challenged in fitness apps.
But my users want
everything to be easy.
And you're mostly right.
When it comes to the
transactional parts
of your app, when it comes
to your login screen,
the navigation of your
UI, yes, make these things
as easy as possible.
But when it comes to the
core experience of your app.
The reason your users are there.
That's the time
to challenge them.
not to say, well,
that's fine for Freeletics.
But to ask, what is the
Freeletics of finance look
like?
What would drive the
most passionate Pinterest
or Memorize users to
get outside and make
their things with others?
And obviously,
there's tons of room
to talk about this in games.
So we talked to the
indie developers
at Butterscotch Shenanigans.
These are the makers of
the hit game, Crashlands,
and the forthcoming Levelhead.
Obviously, a studio
who knows how to
connect with the
values of their users.
And they told us about
a constant debate
when they're making games.
Something that I'm sure
a lot of you have faced.
How much information
should we give our users?
Should we tell them
everything they need to know?
Make things super easy but
risk some users leaving if this
is too boring, too obvious?
Or do we hide some things?
Give our users that wonderful
feeling of challenge
and discovery, but we risk
losing some users if we make
it too difficult.
Well, for Crashlands,
they lean towards
guiding the player.
Through in-game
instructions like this one,
their players were never unclear
on exactly what the next step
in their game should be.
They always knew
exactly what to do.
But these guys
are experimenters.
So they made one exception.
This is the Mega Gong, the most
powerful weapon in the game.
And I can see on your faces--
this is a fish sword you want.
I can tell.
And this was a fish sword
their users wanted too.
So for this one, they made
things more difficult.
They didn't give their
users all the information.
They hid things.
They made real challenges.
Users were going
to have to complete
tasks that had about a 1
in 1,000 chance of success.
And what do you think happened?
Did the users who
love this game leave?
Throw up their hands and quit
because it was too difficult?
Just the opposite.
This challenge is what
drove users to their forums.
Inside the Butterscotch
Shenanigans forums,
you saw users posting
screenshots, coming together,
trying to solve this together,
strategizing with each other.
This was a single player game.
And this weapon, this
challenge, became
what brought users together.
So what would your
users work for?
What's the awesome
fish sword they're
waiting for you to build?
Now, today is about
mindsets, again.
And this one can take a
little bit of a mindset shift
for some of us
because challenges
can be counterintuitive.
We all want to make things
that are easy to use.
We want to make those slippery
sales funnels that our users
can slide right down.
And when it comes to
the transactional parts
of our apps, we
absolutely should.
But again, when it comes
to the challenge, when
it comes to the core
experience of your app,
this is the time
to think about--
what will my users
reach out to others for?
What will they really work for?
Think about the best
stories you hear
and the best stories you tell.
The things you keep
telling around your office.
I'm betting that these aren't
the stories of everything
coming easily.
Of everything working out.
Of you always knowing
exactly what to do.
The best stories are
full of challenge.
And your users want it too.
So let's think again about this
decision we're facing tomorrow.
This project we're working on.
And now, let's
ask this question.
Will this inspire our users to
stretch beyond their limits?
Because answering
this question is
how we're going to get, again,
to that 50% of users who'll
be more engaged with apps that
they can use with their friends
and family.
This is how you'll
get them to reach out.
This is how you're going to
connect with the 2/3 of users
who say they'll be
more engaged with apps
that they feel an
emotional connection to.
You're going to create
that emotional connection
by genuinely challenging them.
So as we're continuing
to build these bridges
of connected
experiences-- we've talked
about how to get to
know our users better.
We've talked now about how to
use challenges to motivate them
to reach outside of themselves.
Now let's talk about how
to bring them together.
Because we said at the beginning
that your users have this
desire for connection.
They want to be around
other people who
love the things that they
love, who care about the things
they care about.
But so often what we're
pushing our users towards
are individual actions.
We're tracking the things
that individual users
do to meet metrics that
individual users can meet.
It's like we're a bookstore
and our only KPI is, did we
sell one book to one person?
Did one person buy one book
and they got out of here?
Great.
Success.
That's fine.
But it's awfully limiting.
Because the opportunity
that bookstores
have is to create
the kind of space
for unexpected connections that
truly make experiences magical.
That feeling that your
customers, your users,
can have when they can
say, I came here for this,
but I found that.
Sociologists have known about
this effect for decades.
They tell us that one of the
keys to developing friendships,
to developing relationships,
is to have repeated
unplanned interactions.
Repeated unplanned interactions.
It's the way that you just bump
into people in the bookstore,
in the coffee shop.
What we found in our
research is that this is not
limited to the physical world.
Your apps and games
can do it too.
I spoke to a user of
the game Dice Duel.
I don't know if they're
in the house tonight.
But this is Dice Duel.
This is a game for
virtually playing dice.
And she told me about how I
recommended this app to my dad
because I had played dice games
with him when I was a kid.
I thought he would like it.
She was right.
He loved it.
What happened next
she was not expecting.
She said, this is a guy who
won't check his text messages,
who won't use WhatsApp.
But inside of Dice Duel,
we are having the kinds
of repeated unplanned
interactions that are
strengthening our relationship.
I can always find him there.
And when I tell that story,
people often tell me, well,
that's just luck.
Some of our users are always
going to find connection
around our apps and games.
We don't need to design for it.
We can't even design for it.
And I'm telling you
that it's not luck.
Bookstores and coffee shops
are designed experiences.
When you spend time
in them, you can
see how they're designed
to send traffic in ways
that put people together.
Many of you probably know the
story of the Pixar building
that is designed to bring people
from different departments
together in unexpected
and unplanned ways
because they knew that it
was those moments where
the real magical ideas
were going to come from.
Your apps and games
can do the same thing.
Let's take a look at
how Gameloft does it.
Again, inside of
Dragon Mania Legends.
This is Neena.
And Neena told me that like
so many Dragon Mania Legends
players, she came
for the dragons.
But what she found was
something very different.
She said she'd been
playing for a little while.
She was getting bored.
And she decided to
join an in-game clan.
For anyone who doesn't
know, clans and leagues
inside of games are like
teams where 20 people work
together, share resources,
strategize, compete
against other teams.
And the team that Neena
joined was very intense.
This is a group of
people that vets
new users to make sure they
can stay committed to the game.
They want people from
all over the world
so that someone can be grinding
24 hours inside the game.
And they formed
a real community.
They maintain a separate
Facebook Messenger group
where they share pictures
of each other's puppies,
and keep up with
each other's lives,
and get each other excited about
what's coming next in the game.
This was not what
Neena came for.
Neena came for the dragons.
She found a real community of
people who love what she loves,
who cares what she cares about.
And it wasn't luck.
It wasn't coincidence.
Gameloft designed
this space for her.
I'm going to tell you about
two decisions they made.
One, inside of this team, there
is an in-game chat window,
so people can communicate
with each other.
That one might seem obvious.
But I've seen a lot
of apps and games
now that try to appeal
to the idea of teams.
And they tell a bunch of users,
you are all on a team now.
But there is no way for them
to interact with each other.
Or they put users
into multiplayer modes
where they play a bunch
of random people one time
and leave wondering
if they were even
playing against real people.
That chat window is how Neena
is able to have those repeated
unplanned connections
with those people grinding
inside the game 24 hours a day.
Gameloft also makes it
really easy for people
to not just join these
teams, but to leave them.
Because we're talking about
sub-communities of players.
Very specific cultures.
There's a good chance
you're not going to join
the one you want right away.
They make it easy to
leave and try another one.
Gameloft is designing
this experience.
And players like
Neena are filling it
with that magical
feeling of connection.
So again, today
is about mindsets.
And what we're asking
you to do with this one
is to think beyond individual
users taking individual actions
that you can easily measure
with individual metrics,
and think about
how you can drive
towards deeper connections.
Real meaningful storytelling.
The kind of thing that's
going to drive long term
engagement with your apps.
Because let's look at the
users we've talked about.
Neena was getting bored.
The community is who
she plays for now.
If we go back to
Elliot and Freeletics,
Elliot told me he
downloaded Freeletics
so he could work out alone.
Now that community is
who he plays for now.
Neena and Elliot have both been
daily active users for years.
These developers are solving
problems that all of you face.
How do we keep long term
interest for our users?
How do we keep
subscriptions going?
How do we create surprise, and
delight, and novelty for them?
Well, think about where you find
those things in your own life.
You find it in the bookstore
and in the coffee shop
when you keep running
into your friends.
Maybe you find it on an
airplane when you strike up
a great conversation
with someone
who just happens to have
the same backpack as you.
Maybe it's at a conference
where you come to learn more
about your industry
but you leave
thinking about all the
new friends you've made.
Each one of these things
can feel like luck,
can feel like coincidence.
But they're all
designed experiences.
And you can design
those experiences too
by taking a look
at that decision
that you're facing right
now and plugging it
into this question--
which is, will this move
us towards a culture
where relationships thrive?
Are we creating the
spaces for the kinds
of unexpected connections that
make experiences truly magical?
Because this,
again, is how we're
going to get to
that 50% of users
who find their apps and
games through word of mouth.
The 50% of users who'll
be more engaged with apps
that they can use with
their friends and family.
Answering this question
will do that for us.
So at Context Partners,
we had such a great time
getting to know these
developers, and users,
and players.
We had so many ideas
and stories that we've
been kicking around
that have really
re-inspired and reinvigorated
us in our own work.
And I hope these
three mindsets have
done the same thing for you.
We've talked about getting
to know your users better
by using personal affinities
to dig into their underlying
values, how to use challenges
to motivate them to reach out
to others, and how unexpected
connections can truly
make experiences magical.
I'll bring Jared back up now.
JARED COLE: Thank you, Sam.
So we've been talking
a lot about bridges
and connecting people.
And it's through these
moments that you really
start to see things happen.
Once you realize that
you're not the only one that
loves this app or feels
this way about the game.
These are the experiences
that drive community.
Experiences like the
one that we're all
having now, where
you can connect
with the people around you
over the idea of connecting
with people is a
task worth taking on.
And so what should you do
after you leave the room today?
Bring back mindsets,
not tactics.
Think about how you can bring
these into your work every day.
We've introduced the
questions about how
to create those spaces to
inspire people to reach
beyond themselves, and asking
if this is the kind of work that
will move toward those places
where relationships can really
thrive.
And as you do that, I want to
leave you with one question.
Where will I build
bridges today?
Thank you.